In our previous video, we studied different
parts of the human eye and their
functions.
In this video we are going to roughly see
how light propagates
inside the eye and how we are able to see
the objects around us.
And for that, we will consider a simplified
2 dimensional image of our eye!
So how does light travel inside?
Suppose we are looking at an object which
is some distance away…
Not too far
away though.
The light from that object enters our eye
and falls on the
CORNEA first.
What is cornea?
It is this curved and transparent outer layer
guarding the entrance to the eye!
First, the light is REFRACTED by the cornea.
This refracted light then travels
through the transparent fluid present in between
which is also called the
AQUEOUS HUMOR.
From this fluid, light then enters the pupil
and falls on the
lens inside.
This eye lens is a biconvex lens and it refracts
the light such that the all light
coming from a point on an object is FOCUSED
on the retina.
This is where the
image is formed.
Clearly the image that you see is a real and
inverted image!
But wait, we don’t really see the world
around us being upside down do we?
We see everything as is because this image
again gets upright in the brain.
We
know that these light signals travel through
the optic nerve as impulses and
travel to this part of the brain.
It is known as OCCIPITAL LOBE.
However before
this light falls on the retina, it first travels
in the space between the retina and
the lens.
This space is filled up with another transparent
fluid called VITREOUS
HUMOR.
Yes, there’s aqueous humor between the cornea
and the lens!
And
there’s vitreous humor between the lens
and the retina!
So this is how the light travels inside the
eye!
There are multiple refractions
occurring inside!
In fact much of the refraction occurs before
the light reaches
the lens!
Let me get a bit technical here!
Look at the eye closely.
What are the different mediums through which
light
travels before it reaches the retina!
There’s air; then there’s cornea; then
we
have the aqueous humor; then the lens; and
finally through the vitreous
humor.
And here are the approximate refractive indices
of the media!
Now if you notice, the refractive indices
of air and the cornea are largely
different!
Whereas the others are not significantly different.
Hence most of the
refraction happens are the air-cornea interface.
Refraction does occur at other
interfaces too, but not as much as this interface!
The lens also refracts the light; however
its main function is to make sure all
the light from a point is focussed on the
retina only!
Yes, it just fine tunes all
the light so that the image is formed on the
retina and not anywhere else.
But
how does the lens do that?
We have studied the properties of images formed
by biconvex lens in the past.
We know that for different positions of an
object, the image is formed at
different locations.
But this does not happen inside the normal
eye.
The lens
inside the eye always forms the image on the
retina only!
Not in front or
behind the retina!
Why is that?
This is because the size and the shape of
this lens are NOT fixed.
This is a
flexible lens composed of fibrous jelly like
material.
Therefore the lens can
temporarily change its shape up to a certain
extent.
But how?
This movement of the lens is controlled by
muscles called CILIARY MUSCLES.
One of the most widely accepted theories says
that when the ciliary muscles
are in a RELAXED position, the lens is THINNER
and hence it has a LARGER
FOCAL LENGTH.
And when these muscles contract, thickness
increases and
hence the focal length decreases.
So when the object is nearer, the lens increases
its thickness to form its image
on the retina.
For a faraway object it becomes thin and the
image is again
formed on the retina.
So that’s the whole point.
By adjusting its shape, the lens
makes sure that the image is always formed
on the RETINA only!
Not in front
or behind the retina!
Ciliary muscles relaxed  Lens Thinner  Larger
focal length
Ciliary muscles contract  Lens Thicker
 Smaller focal length
The ability of the lens of the eye to adjust
its focal length accordingly is called
ACCOMMODATION.
Now obviously there is some limit to which
the lens can increase or decrease
its focal length.
One of the cases is when the object is too
close to the normal
eye…
If you take an object very close to your eye,
the image appears to be
distorted.
You will not be able to see the object clearly.
This is because the
image is not formed on the retina.
In that case we have to strain our eyes in
order to view the object with clarity.
When we strain our eyes, what we’re
actually doing is trying to reduce the FOCAL
LENGTH of the lens.
We can try
that but we will still not be able to see
the object clearly!
So how should we fix that problem?
The solution is simple.
The object should be kept at such a distance
from the
eye that the image is formed on the retina
only.
This distance is called
MINIMUM DISTANCE of the object from the eye…
and for the normal eye its
value is around twenty five centimetres.
Ok, so what did we learn from this video?
We learned how the light propagates inside
the eye.
Most of the light is
refracted at the air-cornea interface and
then falls on the lens after travelling
through aqueous humor.
The lens then focuses all the light THROUGH
the
vitreous humor, ON the retina by adjusting
its focal length.
In next video, we will study a few eye defects.